"I HAVE A DREAM"?
THIS IS TOTAL COMMUNIST STUFF.
IT ALL MAKES
SO MUCH SENSE
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT IT
LIKE A CRAZY PERSON.
J. EDGAR HOOVER
CALLED A PRESS CONFERENCE,
AND HOOVER TELLS THESE REPORTERS
THAT HE'S INVITED,
WHO ARE ALL WOMEN
FOR SOME REASON,
MARTIN LUTHER KING
IS THE MOST DISHONEST MAN
IN AMERICA.
ONE OF HOOVER'S UNDERLINGS
IS SAYING,
[whispering]
MAYBE YOU SHOULDN'T
TALK [bleep]
ABOUT MARTIN LUTHER KING.
MAYBE YOU SHOULD BE NICE.
AND HOOVER'S LIKE, [bleep] YOU,
I'M GONNA TELL THE TRUTH.
THEY MEET
IN J. EDGAR HOOVER'S OFFICE.
MARTIN LUTHER KING SAYS,
HEY, J. EDGAR HOOVER,
I LOVE EVERYTHING
YOU'VE EVER DONE.
MAYBE WE COULD
JUST BE BETTER TEAMMATES
SO WE CAN ACHIEVE PEACE
THROUGHOUT AMERICA.
AFTER THOSE FIRST TWO MINUTES,
J. EDGAR HOOVER DECIDED,
DUDE,
NOW IT'S MY TURN.
IT'S MY TURN TO SAY
WHAT'S ON MY MIND.
THE FBI DOES THIS.
THE FBI DOES THAT.
THE FBI IS HELPING YOU HERE.
THE FBI IS HELPING YOU THERE.
AND HE JUST GOES ON AND ON
AND ON AND ON
ABOUT HOW AWESOME THE FBI IS.
AND AFTERWARDS, ONE OF
MARTIN LUTHER KING'S FRIENDS
CALLS HIM AND SAYS,
WHAT WAS THAT LIKE,
MEETING WITH MARTIN LUTHER KING?
[laughs]
I'M SORRY.
THAT'S HOW DRUNK I AM.
OKAY.
WHAT WAS IT LIKE,
MEETING
WITH J. EDGAR HOOVER?
AND MARTIN LUTHER KING WAS LIKE,
DUDE, I'LL TELL YOU.
J. EDGAR HOOVER, HE'S JUST
A OLD MAN WHO TALKS TOO MUCH.
HE'S CRAZY.
J. EDGAR HOOVER WAS LISTENING
TO EVERYTHING THAT HE SAID.
HE WAS LIKE,
WHAT THE [bleep]?